this is fight fighters and literally as
I'm doing this I'm looking up the code
on my phone here because I realize like
oh I didn't get that yet so curio yes
Maybelle o insist cool quick anyway this
was the first episode Doug showed me cuz
I know it was a month ago yeah I just
said you have to see the show you have
to see gravitas I said and the very
least you got to see this episode he was
like one of those five-year-olds who had
just discovered Pokemon back in like
1999 or something except it's not
Pokemon it's gravity falls and it's so
much better
yes we're reminded me of our cousins
back when they were younger and we were
just like but so he was like that and
they having no reference and I had a
number of fans of his like you have to
watch gravity falls so I was like
alright all watching them but that's
exactly what it's exactly what he did
and then he put it on and the first
thing I said was what's with that kid's
voice and then this is also yeah and
then the second thing I said was alright
it had me at this joke and then the
third thing I said was 80s awareness
fuck yeah
pretty much three minutes in I think I
was sold I'm like god dammit they're
returning us like shit something else I
have to watch you show some are almost
like a hassle now and that's funny
that's a problem such a commitment then
I have to watch it and then if I missed
an episode
other people like but you didn't see the
episode and like God it sucks to live in
America mm-hmm but yeah so we have awful
people but yeah we have another episode
it kind of based on the love triangle
again but the outcome is so funny that
doesn't matter love triangle episode I
really liked because the jokes were so
well written I didn't give a shit that
it was because the love triangle aspect
of it led to these great jokes they were
all based around Street Fighter yeah
and this is obviously you know obviously
based on Street Fighter and the the
attention to the detail that they get
like you know standstill this is as soon
as I can stand I mean it's you know it
when he goes up in a tree and he can't
look up what he sees a car and he beats
the crap out of it to get prizes and now
it I think that's what I love is like I
think the 80s awareness going on
particularly in this episode but there
are other episodes as well where it's
like you can tell these guys are aware
of like the 80's 90's culture and are
able to tap into it it's really
entertaining for old guys well and what
I like you know we had a whole it like I
need to explain this episode you know
Robbie says he's gonna get in a fight
with dipper and somehow I was like who's
that douchebags CMIT and he gets this
video game character and come out that's
a street fighter ish character and he
thinks he can use him to win the fight
and sure enough the character's insane
cuz he only lives in the video game
world of like ultra violence and things
backfire and he tries to you know it
dipper at the end kind of takes a
beating which I was like wow you know
it's very good fellas you know everybody
takes a beating sometimes where'd you
get I'm kind of like oh the important
thing is you kept your mouth first court
case but yeah I like the fact that it's
like on the one hand I'm like what is
pretty violent but then the other hand
is like he he kind of stood up to it he
had to take the consequences and
responsibility for his actions and yeah
he takes a beating you know but he also
uses mine to get around it and it worked
out and again I like that they they
follow through with when somebody has to
go all the way with something it's not
like you know okay I've learned this but
I don't have to accept the punishment of
it you know cuz it happens a lot
particularly with Disney in the past and
they don't do that here they follow
through with it I really like that even
if it is got a violin and they'll save
us - the only other major thing I have
with this episode that is a good thing
in my opinion we had that one where was
a dipper vs. manliness or something like
yeah it was it was funny but was this
very kind of obvious for
commentary I think it's kind of saying
commentary here but I think done a lot
better because I think there's always
this thought that like it you know well
you're just upset because this is too
feminine and too pink and you're
bad-mouthing that anything can be to
anything and I think sorry the street
fire element that's just a good example
of like something that's too violent too
masculine to all this stuff and because
this character clearly doesn't think all
he knows is violence and anger and and
just these great big cliches and can
show how that can be pushed way too far
as well and I think just that same
message when you're sitting on ER and
you didn't say like Dante Basco um and I
just think that message was done a
little bit better here
are you keeping an open your pants yes
so I I just like the way they they do
that I I thought it was a little bit
more subtle yeah well the message in
that element was a little bit more
subtle and maybe even wasn't intended I
just I thought it came across as well
honestly the other thing I have to say
is you can thank this episode for these
V Lawrence cuz it was this episode he
showed me first that got me hooked oh my
god I'll do this yeah and trying to do
is anything else I do have a strange
story unrelated to this episode but
remind me of first seeing the show so
this isn't actually the first I saw of
gravity falls I did come over one time
before that I think to preview the NC
before we uploaded it and you had the
episode with the president the president
and it was a scene where they were on
the train and I forget the exact line of
dialogue but it was something like you
know but you can't do that it's like of
course again like I married a weasel
once or something and I was just like my
job was just on the ground I was staring
at it yeah and I'm just like this makes
no sense
and then Doug's like oh watch it and
trust me it will and I'll be damned if I
I've forgotten about that moment and
when we hit that moment again on top of
the train with the crazy
pantsless president everything I'm just
like wow this totally makes sense now
because I was just watching it now and
it was like yeah I have no questions
about this scene makes perfect sense to
me in context in context yeah that is
the glory of this show so I added this
episode's a lot but we we love Street
Fighter growing up and we love the
pixely animation and stuff like that I
think we're not that I think was the
coolest thing the way that they made it
look 16-bit yeah and you know he wants
to give us some food he's like put it on
the ground what's on the ground a walk
so far it's a consume it in even the
cutscenes like you know what the wise
things and everything how clever is I
have to wonder something cuz I remember
when you showed it to me the first time
I thought the same thing which is we
were up in the 80s and the early 90s
how many kids born it was 2014 kids born
after 2000 hours Street Fighter where do
you think it's there's no street fight i
mean i guess the vs. games you know it's
Street Fighter vs. Capcom vs. Marvel vs.
DC okay like man like I you know it you
know if somebody does like a pong joke
we weren't alive when pong came out but
we know what it was we know it yes three
years old but maybe you know what I mean
pong we had the Atari okay but not
moving no no I mean like the arcade game
like you know I felt like the first
arcade game you know pong and I was like
a huge deal it's like we know you know
the attraction we get when people are
like let's move on I'm mad about what
the kids are doing nowadays by all the
hip and Portlandia and but it's pretty
obvious now that everything is retro you
know I mean it already I'm just curious
I'm not talk about okay like kids are a
bear you know guys are about 20 I'd say
even like in high school now but I'm
talking about like 10 year olds watching
this show are they Street Fighter where
do they have 80s awareness you even if
not or 90s early 90s awareness
if not it's really it's a video game
character that like that looks so much
of the ones they may play on like their
phones or so I mean I personally think
it gets really really cool and I'm just
wondering if good eye on Astana I don't
talk to children I don't walk up to them
on the street and go you buy a fighter
do you play Street Fighter 2 do you
remember how cool it was so I did once
the judge said never again and that's
why I have to wear this ankle bracelet
but yeah I saw I was just curious like
because it's obviously that was aimed
more at us which is what I like about
shows like this but I think what makes
it work is that it's still legitimately
funny on its own yeah but I'm just
curious you know by my guess is a ghost
in catch this is most people watching
the villains are either in high school
or above how many 10 year olds are gonna
chime in and be like I'm course I know
that there's been one or two I've met at
cons I'm always kind of like listen
you're a sweet kid everything but you
should be watching me you need a better
sensor something realize if the MPAA
could rate the internet we'd be at xxx
yeah I mean so even that xxx would still
be I like the low end of Internet
ratings xxx would be your are yeah
they'd have to come up with like you
know dodecagon X or something so yeah
I'm the message by the way if I forgot
is sorry tip for our Wendy's and other
Castle which again how many kids would
get I think they would I I guess I love
you please Super Mario Brothers I think
the last time I did that joke was Super
Mario Brothers you know because you know
because our generation is so obsessed
with this retro media and even the judo
make our kids appreciate kind of it
we're gonna talk about it anyway and
it's no interview so much so it's like
you kind of can't escape it we're
forcing them to enjoy it yeah kind of
they'll get these references cuz well so
yeah that's about it
does the episode I got my brother into
it and I said man you gotta see this at
least this one episode and I was ruined
for life but that's okay because I had
the ultimate revenge twincest winces so
see you next time for more twincest
in cool hwhip